a big challenge for leaders and managers
is to balance the tension between being
directive and specific and allowing for
space for discussion debate and
difference
today on the podcast we'll discuss this
and the ever-changing expectations of
leaders in communication
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome think fast
talk smart the podcast
I'm excited to chat with John Levin who
is the Philip H Knight professor and
Dean of Stanford Graduate School of
Business before becoming Dean in 2016
John spent 16 years in the economic
department at Stanford in 2021 he was
appointed to President Joe Biden's
Council of advisors on science and
technology
well hi John welcome to the podcast I'm
super excited to have you here thanks
Matt great to be here cool let's get
started
as your career has unfolded you've had
more and more opportunities to share
your thoughts with larger and larger
audiences I'm curious to learn more
about this and how you're thinking on
communication has evolved over time my
thinking about communication has evolved
over my career I served as a professor
teaching and when you're giving research
talks it's just everything is about
presenting ideas and information clearly
and maybe even impressing people a
little bit and getting them to change
the way they they think about a problem
in a leadership role so much more of
communication is about connecting with
people establishing shared Humanity
motivating them inspiring them sometimes
challenging them
so I've gone through my career that has
really reinforced to me that the
different purposes that communication
serves to to inform people to connect
with people to motivate and Inspire them
I too have seen over my time how it's
changed and the expectation has changed
and and I think a lot of people who
listen in
have found themselves as their career
has developed they've had to adjust the
way they perceive communication much
like you have and for many people that
can be very challenging it's it's good
to hear that you recognize that any
particular moments or thoughts that
you've had that really helped you make
that shift from talking about your own
research in your own Department to now
being on a larger stage I wish there was
just a single moment when the light bulb
went on and I magically got better or
figured out different ways to
communicate for me it didn't happen that
way it was more of a gradual process of
learning and improving and like anything
communication is a craft and the craft
that you teach and you have to work at
it thank you for that Candor and thank
you for reinforcing the fact that
communication is something you have to
work on in practice very very true in
your six years as dean of the Stanford
Graduate School of Business you had to
address many significant issues
happening on campus and Beyond what are
your thoughts on the role of leaders in
communication in times of ambiguity and
Challenge and do you have any best
practices you've learned that you rely
on
one of the most important things is to
be able to provide Clarity in a timely
way often the way I tend to think about
that is what do people need to know and
how would I like them to feel when they
read a message for me
there's a very complex set of issues
that has arisen on campuses and in
academic leadership that has to do with
how do you communicate about issues that
are going on in the world and the
landscape for that particular question
has changed hugely over the last say
five or ten years where historically
academic leaders were hesitant often did
not rarely communicated about the events
of the day and so forth and today
there's a much higher expectation and a
much greater demand to know you know
where did where did the institution
stand what is the president University
think what do Deans think about
different issues
I find that to be one of the most
complicated and challenging set of
questions in leadership communication
figuring out what to talk about and how
to talk about it wanting to be able to
make clear statements about what I think
or institutional values to reassure
groups of people who really want to hear
something about that but at the same
time
leaving space for people to form their
own opinions to discuss ideas to debate
what's going on because that diversity
of ideas of viewpoints of perspectives
is just so absolutely Central to our
mission
I think in that you've clearly defined a
tension that all Business Leaders need
to to manage which is
how do you step forward and put forth
your position but also live leave space
for people to discuss to debate to
discover and that's a hard tension and
it sounds like part of how you navigate
through that is by thinking through what
do you want people to know and how do
you want them to feel
about those issues and that is something
we've talked about before on this
podcast and I think critical in all
communication it's not just the
information you need to put out there
it's how do people need to feel or do
you want people to feel about it so
thank you in the early days of the
pandemic you started sending out a
weekly email blast that you sent to
everybody in our community here at the
GSB and it relayed information it
offered support and assurance and I
personally found these messages
comforting informative and encouraging
in a time when encouragement was
definitely needed I'm curious about the
specific thought process that went into
those emails as well as your thoughts
about how leaders can find a balance
between being warm and personal which I
thought you did a great job with and
being strong and definitive thanks for
saying that when the pandemic started in
the winter and spring of 2020 there was
just so much going on because we we were
canceling programs international travel
we went online over a weekend people
were working from home they were had to
be on lockdown it was it was just an
incredibly unusual and dynamic situation
and so I started writing to the
community basically just to summarize
the information that people needed you
know what was canceled how we're moving
online who needed to be on campus and I
was basically just writing bullet point
memos to make sure everyone had sort of
common facts and information and knew
what to do
and then within a few weeks I started
writing more reflective emails and so
you know what I was thinking about what
I was reading I was talking to the
experience of having a Passover seder on
Zoom you know other types of strange
experiences that everyone was sharing
and everyone was so isolated and lacking
in the community and I wanted to try to
maintain that
and so I did keep that up through the
main part of the pandemic and I got a
lot of positive responses and
appreciation partly just for putting
that effort in to try to maintain
community
I really found it endearing and it did
build a sense of community when you were
sharing the stories about how it was
affecting your life how it was affecting
your family you would highlight what you
noticed other people doing and it really
served to bring people together and I
think a lesson for everybody listening
is that even in times of stress being
personal and sharing your own experience
can really help Bond people together and
I appreciated that
as you think about the future of
business and business education I'm
wondering what you think about the role
communication is playing now and will
play in the future there is just no
doubt whatsoever that communication is
going to play is going to continue to
play such an important role for Business
Leaders that's true whether they're
communicating individually to their
leadership team or to different people
in their company or to employees or to
customers or to shareholders or
testifying in Congress or to the public
it really is just so important for
people who are in leadership roles to be
able to communicate with Clarity our
students are really fortunate to have
folks like you to help prepare them for
that world such an essential skill thank
you and I agree with you that the role
of communication the pandemic taught us
how critical communication is and when
we're cut off in some ways from our
communication it could be very
challenging let me ask you about a
question that is relevant to someone who
is an economist and the dean of a
business school capitalism is under Fire
these days we're facing problems of
economic inequality climate change loss
of jobs to technology privacy concerns
and many other things
how is the GSB teaching students to
think about capitalism and what is the
role of the school in leading a broader
conversation on the subject I love that
question because I think you're just
spot on with where the world is today
the place I like to start and thinking
about that is just to think about the
extraordinary Triumph that we've had in
this country and in many other places
around the world over the last century
century and a half in the United States
over the last 150 years standards of
living almost doubled every generation
and that rise from subsistence to
Prosperity there's no precedent in human
history and it's been even more dramatic
in countries like China for example that
adopted many elements of capitalism and
so it's just incredibly important to
keep in mind that markets that private
Enterprise coupled with stable political
legal institutions
can be the single greatest engine for
societal progress particularly important
to keep in mind at a business school
because that is the engine we're trying
to build and and support you know at the
same time you're absolutely right you
think of challenges like climate change
inequality the misuses of technology
these are serious issues that we have to
Grapple with in this century and we're
living at a time when our political
system which
in some sense is the right place to deal
with those types of challenges just
seems entirely unable to come to terms
with them and address them in any sort
of reasonable way
and so people you know naturally then
look elsewhere
for for Solutions and for leadership and
so there's they look to business they
look to investors they look to to the
private sector to tackle these market
failures externalities these problems to
be responsive to relative stakeholders
and that just raises all kinds of
hard questions like it's hard enough to
run a business to maximize long-term
value for your shareholders and then
someone asks you to solve global climate
change right you know so when I think
about what we want in educating
students today to be Business Leaders we
want them to dive into those questions
to wrestle with them there's all kinds
of tensions and trade-offs we want them
to really think hard and understand
those complexities and of course we also
believe you know particularly at a place
like Stanford where an epicenter of
innovation we want our students to be
the source of the solutions we want them
to solve problems like climate change to
bring new technologies ideas to Market
with great business models that deliver
them with you know with scale with speed
we hope students when they come here are
going to be inspired to take on big
challenges and then to do it in ways
that will restore people's faith in
business and the ways it contributes to
society
I certainly see as our students leave
here that energy that excitement to do
just that it's one of the greatest
Pleasures I have teaching here it's
incredibly inspiring absolutely it just
renews your faith exactly in exactly
humanity and people every day and every
year when we get a new generation of
students I so agree because the
challenges are formidable and yet the
students leave ready to tackle them and
it's very rewarding
Stanford GSB is one of the most
competitive management education
programs in the world what do you see as
the opportunities for the GSB to reach
and educate even a broader set of
leaders than those fortunate enough to
come here so your question it sort of
alludes to attention in our core model
of education at a place like Stanford
which is we take a very small and highly
selected set of students and we pair
them up with an even smaller and highly
selected set of faculty
that's a magical immersive educational
environment very intense campus
experience
and we hope that the outcome of that is
that students go on graduates go on to
have an outsized impact in the world
at the same time
we need a much larger stronger cohort of
global Business Leaders to help continue
to move toward prosperity and to have
growth and solve the big challenges of
the world
and particularly with the interest that
people have been continuing to learn
throughout their lifetime and the
capabilities that we've developed others
have developed with technology I have a
very strong feeling that places like
Stanford have a tremendous opportunity
and someone's a responsibility to try to
reach and engage with and educate a
broader set of people around the world
and to do that in ways that are
transformative and meaningful and
impactful we do that today through short
on-campus programs we run for executives
or for other leaders in our online
programs our lead program nearly doubled
during the pandemic in programs we run
globally like Stanford seed which we run
for entrepreneurs in Africa and South
Asia and you know we continue to look
for new opportunities to do that and
it's one of the things that I find most
exciting about the future I have
certainly seen your commitment and your
leadership team's commitment to
expanding how this place the business
school but also Stanford reaches people
and I truly appreciate the support you
have of what we do here because we're
trying to reach people as well I think a
podcast like this is such a great
example of the ways that a place like
Stanford can share ideas with the world
and reach a broader audience and give
people a sense of what's going on what
are people thinking you know what
happens here
so before we end I'd like to ask you the
same three questions I ask everybody who
joins me are you up for that let's do it
all right question number one if you
were to capture the best communication
advice you've ever received as a five to
seven word presentation slide title what
would it be
okay I have a story about this which is
maybe 20 years ago
my brother and I were asked to speak at
an event that was in honor of my father
and we were supposed to be the dinner
speakers
and so we wrote to the people organizing
this event we said you know well what
should we say what's going you know what
what do you think and so forth and they
wrote back this incredibly long email
with well maybe you could touch on this
and that and this and that and you can
do it this way and you know oh by the
way maybe tell a joke and sort of say
something about your mom and all this
stuff and
I looked at this email and I was like
wow this is going to be the tough
assignment and my brother immediately
Just Hits reply all and he says got it
standard talk funny touching and short I
love it funny touching and short I think
that's great advice for many of our
communication situations I'm curious how
did the talk go we were short I'll leave
it at that I'm curious John who is a
communicator that you admire and why so
one person is Barack Obama no matter
your political affiliation you have to
admire
President Obama as a communicator he
came and spoke on campus he gave up
incredibly detailed pretty technocratic
talk about social media and
misinformation it was easily an hour
maybe even an hour and a half
and it was mesmerizing he's a wonderful
speaker let me ask you my third and
final question what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe
Clarity connection inspiration very very
important all three and you do all three
of those very well and serve as a good
role model for all of us and I think all
Business Leaders and people developing
their careers can think about how they
can leverage those three together to
help them successfully navigate the
communication challenges that they have
John thank you so much for being here I
appreciate your time your insights your
candor and truly appreciate what you do
for us and for all of our students thank
you Matt thank you so much for having me
on and we're so fortunate to have you
teaching at the GSB and doing this
podcast
[Music]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Michael Riley and me Matt
Abrahams for more information and
episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu or subscribe to our
show wherever you get your podcasts
finally find us on social media at
Stanford GSB